>> Todd: YOU JUST HEARD CARLEY
SPEAK WITH TEXAS CONGRESSMAN
MICHAEL BURGESS.
NOW FLORIDA ATTORNEY GENERAL
ASHLEY MOODY JOINS US NOW.
HOW BADLY DID YOUR GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS EXPOSE IT IS HYPOCRISY
OF THE LEFT ON THIS?
>> Ashley: THEIR PREFERRED WAY
TO ADDRESS THIS IS TO SIT ON
HIGH, DENY THERE IS A CRISIS,
DENY AMERICANS ARE DYING AT
RECORD RATES BECAUSE THE BORDER
IS OPEN AND THERE IS FENTANYL.
WE CAN TELL YOU THERE IS A
CRISIS, I'VE OFFERED SWORN
TESTIMONY FROM THE BORDER CHIEF
THAT SAID THIS CRISIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED, IT IS ENDANGERING
AMERICAN LIVES AND LIVES OF
MIGRANTS.
THEY WILL DECEIVE PEOPLE, SO
WHAT ELSE ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO
BUT TAKE THE BORDER TO THEM
SINCE THEY WON'T COME TO THE
BORDER.
BIDEN WON'T GO, KAMALA HARRIS
WON'T GO, THEY SHOULD SEE WHAT
IS GOING ON SO THEY HAVE TO
ADDRESS THEIR WILLFUL IGNORANCE
OR CALCULATED EVIL.
WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE DONE FOR
AFFEC
AFFECT, THE TOWNS, THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT, WE SHOULD HAVE PUT
FENTANYL ON THERE, TOO AND SEE
HOW MARTHA'S VINEYARD WOULD HAVE
DEALT WITH FENTANYL COMING INTO
THEIR CITY AND HOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO HANDLE THAT.
>> Todd: MORE FROM YOUR GOVERNOR
IN A 15-SECOND SOUND BITE
SUMMARIZES THE PROBLEM.
>> THE MINUTE A SMALL FRACTION
OF WHAT THE BORDER TOWNS DEAL
WITH EVERYDAY IS BROUGHT TO
THEIR FRONT DOOR, THEY ARE SO
UPSET, IT JUST SHOWS THEIR
VIRTUE SIGNALLING IS A FRAUD.
>> Todd: AG MOODY, POTENTIAL
OPPONENT GAVIN NEWSOM URGING THE
DOJ TO INVESTIGATE WHETHER
ALLEGED FRAUDULENT INDUCEMENT
WOULD RESULT IN CHARGES OF
KIDNAPPING UNDER RELEVANT STATE
LAW.
BY THAT REASONING, WOULDN'T THE
DOJ HAVE TO INVESTIGATE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR DOING
THE EXACT SAME THING WHEN IT
CAME TO MIGRANT FLIGHTS THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION SENT TO
WESTCHESTER COUNTY IN NEW YORK?
>> Ashley: EXACTLY.
THE HYPOCRISY, I'VE BEEN SAYING
AND I'VE BEEN IN COURT FIGHTING
AND PROVING THAT THEY ARE
BREAKING THE LAW EVERYDAY WHEN
THEY HAVE OPENED BORDER, WHEN
THEY LET PEOPLE FLOOD IN AND
RELEASE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
INTO THE INTERIOR, THEY ARE
BREAKING THE LAW, THEY HAVE
BECOME PART OF THE CARTEL
CONSPIRACY, HELPING THEM MOVE IT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BY MOVING
PEOPLE AROUND THE UNITED STATES.
POT/KETTLE?
>> Todd: THERE YOU GO.
YOU MENTIONED FENTANYL, I WANT
EXTRAPOLATE.  YOU ARE URGING JOE
BIDEN TO DECLARE FENTANYL A
WEAPON OF MASS DESTRUCTION, WHAT
WOULD THAT DO?
>> Ashley: IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
18 OF MY ATTORNEY GENERAL
COLLEAGUES AROUND THE NATION ARE
SAYING ENOUGH IS ENOUGH, THIS IS
SUCH A POTENT DRUG AND BECAUSE
OF DESTRUCTION OF SECURITY ON
OUR BORDER, IT IS FLOODING OUR
NATION, OUR STATE, IT STARTED
KILLING OUR CITIZENS IN MASS
CASUALTY EVENTS, WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
I'VE SEEN STUDIES THAT SHOW
ABILITY TO KILL LARGE AMOUNTS OF
PEOPLE JUST AS SOMEONE WOULD DO
IF THEY TURN THIS INTO A WEAPON.
BAD ACTOR WORKING AGAINST
AMERICAN INTEREST, IT IS TIME
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE TO TAKE
NOTICE.
I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO ADMIT
YOU HAVE FAILED AT YOUR BORDER,
WE ARE AT GREATER RISK THAN WE
HAVE BEEN IN DECADES.
IT IS TIME YOU STEP UP AND BE
THE PRESIDENCY WE NEED YOU TO BE
AND DECLARE THIS A WEAPON OF
MASS DESTRUCTION, SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE, OFFICE
THAT, WOS
RKS AGAIN
THE CHEMICALS BEFORE THEY GET
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Todd: IT IS LIKE A PLANE
CRASH EVERYDAY.
TO YOUR POINT, YOU HAVE BYPASS
SUPPORT FO